Speaker 1: All right. Let's get into a couple
other different things. There's a clip that's
been making the rounds from a Republican
town hall. Republicans in the House have
been doing this commitment to America agenda
rollout town halls, and it's all weird. And
they're trying to pretend like they care
about policy again. But the policy is all
just cultural issues and random nonsense. So at
this event and House Minority Leader Congressman
Kevin McCarthy was at this event, a woman gets
up, you know, a concerned mom in the audience,
the a prototypical concerned mom. And she lists
a whole bunch of things that she believes are
really Marxism. And in that list, she includes not
bullying people. Not bullying people is Marxism,
according to this Republican mom, supposedly.
And this is a there is so much behind this that
I want to talk about it. But first, let's take
a look at the clip and you'll notice if you're
watching that as she talks about this, Kevin
McCarthy kind of nods along like this makes sense.
Speaker 3: There are many other public
education issues concerning parents like myself,
the slow creep of critical race theory,
diversity, equity and inclusion, right?
Gender identity, and allowing biological
boys to enter girls spaces and sports.
Now we have school, which is
social emotional learning.
Speaker 2: Mm hmm.
Speaker 3:
It's indoctrination disguised as programs like
kindness initiatives or anti-bullying program.
Speaker 1: Anti-Bullying.
Speaker 3: Camps or diversity projects. These are
all Marxist style programs targeting our children.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So, listen, there is a lot
going on here, and there's many, many, many
layers now at the most superficial level.
If you've watched a Trump rally, it does kind of
seem like Republicans are okay with bullying. I
don't know that I would say pro bullying. Maybe
so, but they're at least okay with it. You know,
Trump would get them the hell out of here.
Trump saying to people in the crowd he'll
pay their legal bills if they beat the crap out
of protesters at the rallies. Making fun of the
disabled reporter. I mean, there's bullying of all
sorts. Never mind this entire, like, baiter mail
type stuff that they subscribe to. So one part of
it is they do seem to buy into this kind of strict
father morality idea that getting knocked around
a little bit, getting bullied, whatever it builds
character, it toughens you up, it makes people
strong or whatever the case may be, rather than,
you know, it can really kind of scar people for
life and ruin their lives irreparably in some
cases. So that's one part of it, which is they
actually do seem to sort of be okay with bullying
to some degree, number one. Number two, this is
part of the growing movement that empathy is that
empathy is not desirable. Empathy is feminine in
some way or baiter or whatever. And that's been
increasingly a part of Republican ideology for a
long time. Facts don't care about your feelings as
a popular line. Those things just are what they
are. You got to call things what they are. You
got to call a man, a man, no matter what. You've
got to call. You know, these are the phrases that
they love to use where empathy is a bad thing.
Now. I don't know that they're unable to be
empathetic because we do anecdotally hear about
these stories where, you know, homophobic member
of Congress for 20 years. Turns out they've
got a lesbian daughter or, you know, a gay
nephew or something like that. And all of a sudden
they they change their view. So in those cases,
we say it's really sad that it took something like
that to get them to change their views, but they
were at least able to. So maybe maybe it's not
just about an inability to feel empathy, but then
we have all of these studies about the differences
between what ends up being Republican brains or
Democratic brains. And we see on the Republican
side a larger fear centers, less empathy,
etc.. Now, I think one of the things that can be
deceptive about that is it's not about. Republican
and Democratic brains per say. It's more about
who's more fear oriented, who's more anger
oriented, who's more disgust oriented. They end up
being on the political right, which in the United
States pushes you towards the Republican Party.
And if you consider that maybe there is some kind
of neurological or biological explanation here,
but then the counterpoint to that is sometimes
when they experience something themselves, their
views do change. What I don't like is that this is
all kind of a cover for the fact that they're mad
that in some circles it's not seen as acceptable
to openly bully people who are in some way
different than the majority. It's not okay in some
places anymore, thankfully, to openly bully LGBT
people. A lot of them don't like that. Minorities,
in many cases they would still they they like the
idea of the days where it was okay to more openly
bully or poorly treat minorities and now they're
upset. It's considered woke that you can't do that
anymore. That's at the crux of all of this stuff.
And absent policy, because the Republican Party
has given up on policy. When's the last time you
heard a serious discussion involving Republicans
about what tax rates should be? They. They don't
do it anymore. It's gone. They're just not doing
it anymore. When is the last time they genuinely
talked productively about American foreign policy,
other than just criticizing Biden because he both
didn't do enough and did too much by spending too
much money. When it comes to Ukraine. They don't
even pretend to be about policy anymore. This
new movement where this mom concerned mom spoke,
it's them pretending to care about policy again,
even though they clearly don't. And it's just
about bemoaning the fact that they can't treat
all the same people horribly, that they used
to treat horribly, truly disgusting stuff.